on the Costa Rican forest floor sits the
tiny strawberry poison dart frog no
bigger than a thumbnail and even smaller
than that is her tiny tadpole
unlike other frog species the strawberry
poison dart frog mom transports the
tadpole on her back
a strawberry poison dart frog has to
climb this tree and find somewhere to
park the tadpole in a nourishing body of
fresh water and so begins one colossal
amazing awe-inspiring commute this
Grammy Lea add channels rain and mist
into a micro spring perfect for the
little one the strawberry poison dart
frog makes the climb then drops junior
into just the right daycare center
but mom frogs business isn't finished
here haha not by a long shot
mom's making the rounds to check on the
other tadpoles she dropped off in other
reservoirs each tadpole gives off unique
vibrations that say yeah it's me and I'm
hungry
so mom lays a special non-fertile egg
this special egg dinner is a brilliant
strategy for survival what can go wrong
well a thirsty coati might appear after
all the mothers work this carnivore
could gargle down the water swallowing
the tadpole chuck it's always something
isn't it